[Applause]
oh my God Regina Hall I mean I just
can't even tell you how much I love you
I'm so excited
to like get to know you well I feel the
same way as I've been a fan of yours
since like forever I mean everyone has
like I'm adding myself to a long list
but yes forever as we were going to the
commercial break I did ask you a
question about would you go on a date in
a U-Haul yeah yes is it a first date
though
it it sounded like Ross was pitching it
as a first date but I don't think it has
to be I think it's just a you know a
date I it well you know if it were like
Brad Pitt that'd go first date but if it
but it but if it were someone else I
would know I because it could he could
kill me in the U-Haul like I could die
you know if you don't mind do you mind
just bringing it down a notch okay good
there's something about the floor that
feels engaging it just
now you said if Brad Pitt was in the
U-Haul if he were in the U-Haul I would
go first date I heard he is well then
we'd be ready
yeah meal a mattress yeah who wouldn't
getting it right Brad Pitt came up right
now on a tricycle right I'm in you'd hop
on yes so would I okay so we are both
single
um
have you been on any apps I have not
been on any apps like I'm not good on on
the um on like Social Media stuff well
don't worry on my dating app that I'm on
do you like it
um well you know it's weird because I
definitely am like all right today you
seem interesting and then all of a
sudden they'll say hi and I'm like oh
good oh and then you get nervous I'm
like yes it's so bizarre like and it's
hard to like someone from a picture I'm
your personality first me too so how do
you meet a guy you know friends do you
get set up I had one set up and it went
it went horrible it was really bad we
got an argument so I was going to say I
want a top line of what makes a horrible
date you already gotten an argument we
got in an argument because he was like I
don't want my wife to work and I want
two kids but he already had one kid and
I was like well why do I have to have
two if you already have one and he was
like because I went to by my wife and I
said that is the most selfish thing you
have too and then the argument started
because he said you couldn't if you're
married you couldn't spend more than 500
on a gift right for the other for the
other person without permission and I
said well why do I need permission what
if I what if your husband's been talking
about a watch and you want to surprise
them whatever or like or sure I don't
know and it's more than whatever and he
said well that's money that could be
going towards the children which in
theory is nice but I said but I wasn't
supposed to be working anyway right so
you weren't even counting on my money
your money should be going towards the
kids and then he wanted one joint bank
account and I said but then
thank you
this is all on the first date all of it
sounds wrong right
the only thing that's a silver lighting
to this absolute sociopath
is that the one thing that I feel lately
is we used to vilify does anyone know
that Jack Berger Post-It note on sex in
the city right cultural phenomenon it he
breaks up with her on a Post-It it says
I'm sorry I can't don't hate me oh yeah
now we thought that was so awful yeah
what a jerk yeah Jack Berger looks like
the nicest most clear
directional informative Gentleman on the
planet in the age of ghosting yeah yeah
and because he left the note I can't
thank you it's my turn to start healing
and moving forward and I can't and this
guy in a similar way but a very
different approach lets you know move on
yeah like this isn't a candidate right
away yeah if there's this guy came up
with 20 criterias that are insane what
is one thing that
is top of the list for you
compassion and some hard stuff yeah you
know I want like
some loss a couple of Health crises like
I need some stuff like you know we're
like 100 right because that's
that's the hard stuff so I need you to
have had some stuff like well and how do
they cope with that and how did they
cope with coping method right and you're
going to need that speaking of coping
mechanisms is it true when you would
have a breakup you would go ride a
roller coaster I my friend Michelle
whenever we'd have a breakup we'd go to
Six Flags
did you do that
and go ride the roller coasters and like
we go in the afternoon ride the roller
coasters get like bad snacks and just
have a day yeah yeah it's really good it
also sounds like your girlfriends are so
important to you girlfriends are
everything and you do trips with them I
I do whatever I can with them when we
can go do trips when we go do dinner
when we go to each other's houses if we
go to watch movies like I love my oh or
just literally talk on the phone I heard
you went to Vegas with your girlfriends
yes what'd you do we had dinner with
Prince oh my and he performed
on a stage when he was in when he was in
in Vegas doing his show I love love love
Prince
[Music]